hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
find out if they grew up classy or if
they grew up trash baby I'm your host H
Foley coming at you on a beautiful day
here in Astoria Queens where the bodies
are stacking hi I'm not gonna lie it's
getting a little dicey over here my
co-host the second he saw trouble he was
the first man in a lifeboat on the
Titanic coming at you somewhere in
southern New Jersey our old pal Kippy
Kevin James Ryan everybody what's up
buddy down here in Casablanca studios
yet again I got the hideout
yeah I mean there's free I'm at I'm at
my parents vacation home in South Jersey
and there's definitely a lighthouse
theme going on here and teach a man to
fish and hole sit in a boat all summer
so that's kind of where I'm coming up
good stuff and that voice that you hear
is our very very very special guest our
good pal this gentleman on the show here
today is one of my favorite comedians he
forms all over the city any time I see
this guy's name on the lineup I'm
excited to be on the show you've seen
him on the Chris Gethard show and he was
a writer for the break with Michelle
wolf on Netflix ladies and gentlemen
that is all well and good but we gotta
find out is this guy garbage Greg stone
everybody we first of all let me return
and say both of you human beings when
I'm around you I just feel better you
you literally you know how many times I
go to a New York Comedy Club and you
know these pieces of [ __ ] walking around
me it whole human beings and then I CH
and I go oh we're gonna be safe
you're like the white light Kippy Kip
yeah Kippy came from I was on the road
with and I don't even know him but I was
driving out to a gig with you know Keith
Robinson for who's like you know yeah
the listener if you don't know he's like
an old-school comedian like he's the
king of the cellar table you know and
and by the road he means you were in
Allentown or something like that where
was he headlining we took a road we did
take a road to Allentown is what I was
trying to say yeah and he was acting
like he didn't know my name I was in the
past and if I was in the passenger seat
I was riding shotgun of his car while he
was being driven in the back and he's
going what's this white boys name what's
his name okay something short and then
he came he landed on Kippy we go back to
New York everybody knew me as hippy yeah
yeah do i I love I love him he's one of
these guys who if you can take him one
of two ways you can go
ah [ __ ] this guy hates me [ __ ] him or
you can go no no I'll make him it right
back and he'll love you yes yeah first
time I ever met him was when all this ti
[ __ ] was going on and I walked I'm
walking the back of the table and he's
sitting there he just screaming di was
right I don't know if you remember but
TI like asked his like daughter's
pediatrician to be like see if she's
still a virgin or something yeah people
everyone all the you know all the like
super liberal comedians were there being
like this is [ __ ] up and he's staring
in their face going gee I was right it
was right it was like just digging into
them I was one of the funniest things
he's absolute he's the absolute best not
another great stories we all went to see
the Ninja Turtles movie that came out
because he takes a lot of comedians we
all go to see midnight showing of like
big movies that come it's like a New
York Comedy thing and like yeah so we
want to see the turtles and the whole
week leading up we'd see them in the
village or whatever going you about that
turtle life are you about that turtle
life
so it was like the first you know the
reaming the first remake and so we went
and obviously the movie was [ __ ]
terrible and we made it through like 20
minutes and it gets too and we also
realize you know this movie's gonna be
bad and it gets to a point of complete
silence he goes man [ __ ] these Turtles
he stands up and walks out down the hall
I did it was [ __ ] phenomenal
that's hilarious you can get a theater
cracking up these days that's pretty
good man that's not too shabby it is fun
girl first time I went to movies with
him it was cotton brought me and I'm
like all nervous and like everybody's
there you know organize those movie
nights [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] high school
you know who's seen with who who's this
and that and he's sitting there talking
to cotton I walk up and he's like why
the [ __ ] did you bring this white boy he
probably the same guy he probably thinks
you need the same person he probably
does I would always guarantee it I love
that when comedians call me by a
different name like that's that's like
one of my favorite I never correct them
like nobody killed Martin Lauri kill
Martin thought I was Tim Dylan for about
three years was the best my career has
ever been oh yeah that was the closest
to getting on Rogen you'll ever be
alright but that's neither here nor
there we're going to talk about mr. Greg
stone Greg I wouldn't know a little bit
tell us how you tell us where you grew
up I'm not sure are you a Long Island
guy I think you're a Jersey guy right Oh
baby I'm dirty Jersey oh yeah we gotta
go we gotta do a screening process yeah
man I'm from like a blob from town
Bloomfield
which is a block out of Newark and he's
I grew up a block out of Newark in East
Orange so it's like 30 40 minutes away
that my dad was from the Bronx so I
spent the weekends in the Bronx so I was
like divorced family [ __ ] what was that
like what was the house was like an
apartment or was it like suburban what
was the town looking like I mean I it
was it's like you know it's it's houses
it was like a small house but we live
very close to each other you know like
we I my next-door neighbor we had like a
can and a string we
nothing wrong with that's awesome
yeah Leave It to Beaver we did it and
then we're like this is stupid cuz he
could just hear me cuz I'm speaking loud
enough he can hear me
and then we stole some five-year-olds
Power Ranger walkie-talkies that did
that that kid was crying yeah that was
the move man you always wanted to have
the walkie-talkies where you could talk
to your friend the houses were too far
apart you couldn't hear anybody but
that's [ __ ] pretty sweetie you can
pull that that's like something at a big
yeah that's real goony [ __ ] right there
very Goonies love the Goonies but wait
you said you grew up a block away from
Newark yeah it was like the corner of
Newark and East Orange and in Bloomfield
so like we had where I live literally
was like the most cars stolen like in
America because they would steal the
cars then drive right into Newark and
then the cops wouldn't chase them so
they knew they could just come right on
our block and no one I had a Chevy
Blazer that the window we've got in the
Blazers on other episodes a great car
Chevy Blazer the window wouldn't go out
and then pull it up and then one day I
get pulled over I pull it down and
dropped it by accident shattered the
glass in the window the cop goes well
then that's your ticket that's the
ticket
you poor bastard here you go yeah going
forward it would rain and snow and it
would go into the window and because I
lived in Newark they would steal every
car radio I would put in and I worked in
the car your department at Sears so I
was just stealing car radios from Sears
then they would steal them for me and
they knew that I was replenishing them
and they'd come like we can take him
yeah and the wires would sizzle they
would rain it would sizzle the open
wires and I would be driving person in
the back and a blanket and a snowboard
helmet cuz to keep warm it was who's a
wild ride we can cuz that's what let's
call it a day guys I think that wraps in
garbage quiz we're gonna did they start
putting a request for the radio like hey
Greg can you it's like I don't want to
talk to me look just ask me what you
want what will make you howl get that
[ __ ] for you and then let me have one
let me just have one for the rest it's
just hooking them up with an
and of all the things that I remember
Sears selling I don't remember an
audiovisual Department oh yeah yeah yeah
man we had not anymore
but I think because of me they stopped I
worked with a group of people there's a
dirt bag in Newark that's killing our
whole entire we got to make a move on
this 21:15 head units this week I was a
normal kid I was like a I was not a
thief
at first and I'm worse working with
these dudes who work in Paterson and the
way it went down was this guy's looking
at the radio and he's like here's how I
would steal it whatever and I was like
no that's dumb you'll get caught what
you got to do is return it buy it return
it market down purchases where you get
like I did this whole went through this
it's a whole system and how you do it
he walks up to me about a week later
puts a hundred honors in my hand and he
goes hey thanks again for that tip man
and I went what he was just like yeah I
forgot he was like that was him being
like you're in now and took the money
now you're part of us now you what else
you got it's still a $2,000 Bose
surround system sold it and then gave me
money be brought up on RICO charges the
second you take the money the whole
thing goes down part of the team there's
17 at the time I was 17 go ahead I
remember I think we've mentioned this on
the podcast before is a couple my
buddies worked at Best Buy
like when Best Buy started getting
popular and the system they used to have
was you would like you'd buy the thing
but then you'd go over to like a
conveyor belt where some other guy was
working and it would come down from the
storage up top they had storage upstairs
and would come down like luggage and do
these guys robbing this [ __ ] place I
don't have any [ __ ] stayed in
business dude an arse in my department
in one year you'd looked at where like
if they had a map on where internal
theft was my department was this big on
the map and there was a hundred little
red pins and every other department was
like $1,000 thousand dollars our
department 75 grand and one year was
stolen because three dudes me and like
two other guys and
let me tell you this one other we take
this quick story about this other guy so
was me these two scumbags who I love
we were three scumbags and this one
black guy who was very like a white
black guy like a Carleton kind of guy he
was very professional he was like sweet
he was the best with customers everyone
loved this guy and no one ever talked to
him no we didn't we know whatever talk
to him about the dirty [ __ ] but we don't
involve we wouldn't involve him you know
he's too innocent right we're all doing
our [ __ ] thing one day cops come pull
him out in handcuffs and we what the
[ __ ] did Todd do what the [ __ ] did he do
right I see him
years later the scam he was running
scams he was so I don't even think he
was a sweet guy I think it was just all
character he was doing yeah caught on
wire fraud or something crazy like he
stole in infinity g20 now what does that
mean excuse me yes Sears doesn't sell
cars how does one steal a car from Sears
oh my here is how you do it he at Sears
you could have a disc you could pay your
Discover card at the register so you
could pay your Sears card or your
Discover card a lot of retail places
like yes Hartman so don't play like your
phone bill at Macy's and [ __ ] dude he
bought a car on his Discover card and
then what he would do was so I was
trying to follow the logic here right he
would return he would take an object or
he would return a piece of like a thing
like a car radio for $300 now that means
money is supposed to leave the register
right so now the register is over $300
right now the thing he returned didn't
exist so he would do is he would return
it then mark it down and then have
someone buy it for $3 so some object it
did not exist car radio would get marked
down like 50% then sold now you don't
have to find that thing that was
returned now he takes the difference
right he would take the he would take
the difference between the return point
and the cell
so the difference is the extra money
that's now in the register now he would
then take his Discover card and pay off
the Discover card with the difference so
he's got every month he was doing the
scam to pay the car payment through this
thing and he was doing it it was a
little bit more complicated than that
because you couldn't you wouldn't ring
it up under his number he would do it a
different right look it was his whole
thing but when they fired him they
brought him out handcuffs cuz they knew
he was doing something but couldn't
figure it out so he goes they got me for
absences they didn't get me for stealing
he was like it's like when they got
[ __ ] you know that mob guy on tax
evasion you know I mean like they ain't
Capone on tax evasion component tax
evasion but he would was driving an
Infiniti around that he stole from Sears
and I kneeled to him and I was like
you're the few of the [ __ ] King we
didn't think you were doing anything
it's Wow are you garbage this is [ __ ]
scam school wait well who got him on
hood Sears got him on absences yeah
witness not witness protection what's it
called a loss prevention loss prevention
brought him in what they would do is
they bring you downstairs and they did
this to me a bunch of times they grab
you Sears I saw policemen [ __ ] the
security would bring you in cuffs it was
like that's not now back in the day [ __ ]
yeah Sears was the land of the law back
in the 90s dude they could do whatever
the [ __ ] they wanted it was honest own
yeah I don't think they could I don't
think they couldn't bring you down cuffs
now anymore but or I don't know how it
worked but they cuffed him they brought
me down one time and the right as there
I was 17 right before they're bringing
me down this guy angel looks at me and
he goes whatever they ask you you just
say you don't know yeah you don't know
and he whispered it they bring me down
and they were like looks like people are
a lot of money let's missing from things
what are you doing it and I'm like I
don't know we know you know what do you
know does like I don't know I just stuck
to my guns and they was a sheriff at
Sears dude that is [ __ ] crazy the
Lords of scum working it was us versus
them like every day you see while
stretching them up and you go
hi everybody act cool you know and then
we have one guy who is in on it one guy
who I didn't know but he was getting a
take one of my men was paying him on the
side and see like oh we got Jerry on
cameras today we're good do what you
want to do was [ __ ] [ __ ] wild dude it
was Al and I I left that job because he
got so bad that I was like I don't want
to go to jail and my dad worked there so
my dad was an original Department I'm
like if I get caught my father is gonna
know it's like his pension is gone I we
had this one guy and I'm sorry I want to
[Music]
make a movie about this Goodfellas style
I [ __ ] I kinda want to write a show
about the two sides you know like the
good guys and the bad guys
it would be fun but they had um this guy
Chris and he was a [ __ ] coke head
white dude frosted tips guy not a guy
starts working with us and he's just
blatantly stealing [ __ ] right and we're
like you know you're gonna get us all
pinched right so we were like yo this
guy yo man you got to get out of here
man you're too crazy you can't just do
this [ __ ] and he just kept stealing and
security kept coming up there was so we
had like we were you know we were
shuttered we weren't really doing much
at the time uh he eventually but he you
know like so what I did was I had these
we had these stickers that you put on
like CDs that would send the alarms off
and one of these fun bits we would do is
you've walked behind someone you just
kind of throw it on their back and then
wherever whatever store they went in the
mall it would set the alarm off so we're
walking back and I just [ __ ] threw a
few on them for fur laughs he walks
through the Sears exit the alarm goes
off he Sprint's he Sprint's to his car
gets in his car and takes off and
security is like here what the [ __ ] was
that about man
right we're like you know he's not
coming back he's not gonna they we don't
see him for like three weeks he shows up
shirt-and-tie walks over the registers
like what's up Greg grabs two plastic
bags walks in the stockroom fills the
plastic bags and then just walks out of
the store like just like this
a robbery like we're doing like little
scams and then this [ __ ] guy they
they got him they got all yea I'm
garbage is that what this pot don't
[ __ ] Tony Soprano did the feech
lamanna he was the [ __ ] patsy the
whole time holy [ __ ]
Greg shows up at the guy's house a can
leave a couple of TVs in your house for
a little wagon oil heat on me he's
talking to the other guys he's like
listen I got a coke can he's in he's
ripe for the pickin easy fall guy how do
I know you're not gonna turn on me for a
little bag of white powder [ __ ]
embarrass me
I love how I'm [ __ ] you know devious
tone is well every time stone said
somebody's name he would whisper it we
had this one guy named Chris I mean well
you're definitely [ __ ] garbage I don't
have my numbers in front of me in a pile
but your [ __ ] trash but let's ask a
couple of questions let's play a little
are you garbage with consigliere Greg
stone the whole time they were like high
school kids they're like still running
the [ __ ] nose for the mob those guys
were older they were like 30 or
something or 25 or something but I was
super young and I was like I would just
kind of tell them how to do stuff and
whatever my hands are clean I feel like
Kevin haven't we talked about that if
you were a little kid and didn't have a
job where you worked with men yeah yeah
you're a total [ __ ] these days like
that's how you knew you're garbage like
I remember having like dishwashing jobs
and it was like me and like adults for
sure they were like you they would like
give you your first cigarette or
something they all have the wrong house
tats on them and stuff oh yeah of course
I always I always looked at like the
camp counselor but this kids a [ __ ]
going off to like [ __ ] play oh yeah
meanwhile Monsanto pilato [ __ ] you
know scrubbing pots and pans in the back
my next job I ended up working at
fortunoff's and security which is like
what are we doing here
DiCaprio started working for the feds
and catch me if you can when he finally
went over is it glistening I'll show you
two ways yeah I didn't know now four
stops was different they'd sold jewelry
and [ __ ] so I was like you know I'm not
[ __ ] with this like federal things
yeah it was just a job and all the guys
in security were like ex cops are cops
on a time on the side this one of the
cops swaps out to me one time I'm
probably 20 years old I don't know under
18 19 I don't know welcome to cop smacks
me in the ass so hard I almost threw up
right in front of the head of security
head of security looks at me and goes
hey Greg ei did that bother you is that
a thing I need to write like clearly
sexually harassed me you know in a
violent way and from this guy and the
cop looks and he goes yeah Greg was that
a problem
not a problem sir these odd [ __ ] guns
and [ __ ] just faulting me so that's
[ __ ] funny
all right let's start off with some
questions here Kathy what are you
thinking yeah someone's kind of regular
the ones are becoming regular seems I'm
plus a lot of people are writing in with
their own opinions on it would you do
growing up as a kid did you do milk for
dinner
milk for dinner like at dinner when the
sky was [ __ ] grand for dinner
no it's Foley Foley's family would sit
down with like pasta and meatballs and
sausage and then he would get a [ __ ]
glass 2% right next to it like a [ __ ]
jamoke the day milk hit the table on my
on my my stepfather would have called us
all [ __ ] big bags drink milk except
there was a cop psychopath like no we're
was moon our drinking man it's good yeah
we've asked the milk question probably
almost every episode that was the best
[ __ ] knocking over check cashing
places I'm asking if he drank notes
right there
all right what about in the Hat now
let's say you grew up an Italian
household right I mean my dad my mom was
like mostly Italian my dad is fully
Brahms Italian boy stepdad
was a German cop and he kind of who's
who I was raised by a lot so where does
the stone come from
stone is my mom's name my mom is like
80% Italian but the stones are like
they're like they signed the Declaration
of Independence there's a golf [ __ ]
[ __ ] in history I just used that because
my real last name coral ouzo last name
they don't hire me at [ __ ] shears
with that name did you say your family
signed the Declaration yeah
Thomas stone signed the Declaration of
Independence and he's direct relative to
me and you're stealing blenders at Sears
some American royalty you are so [ __ ]
love it you're getting taken out in
cuffs my parents I need declaration
independence [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah babe what about um so so it was
kind of an Italian household so your mom
was old-school net regard correct uh
really my mom's Italian but she's not
like my dad side is all like they're all
like these [ __ ] Guinea bones you know
my mom was just gonna nurse she was like
she's Italian she knew how to make cook
but she wasn't like my mom was like a
super strong woman she wasn't like you
know just just to know who my mom was
six months ago
I call her I say all right mom see you
later love you she goes by and I went
mom you have to say I love you yeah and
she went you should just know my own
[ __ ] over here let's go I'm finding out
all the [ __ ] that made me a comedian
like later in life that's great so was
there ever any any margarine or Country
Crock in your house as a child no it's
so funny I was so margarine and like
promise and like all those brands that I
didn't even know I I still look at
regular butter is like trash like it's
wrapped up in paper give me a lid give
me a [ __ ] airtight seal what are we
doing come on whip me something whipped
over my house we didn't see a vegetable
tulip my wife is a nutritionist I didn't
see a vegetable till I was 26 years old
yeah man no
was we eat me we drank Coke there was
butter and there were doubts like [ __ ]
that was the 90s was [ __ ] stuffed
crust pizza and wild cherry fantasy
wrong with that high if you were to make
chocolate milk you put the milk in first
or the chocolate oh yeah yeah well I
have a system for this because I do
enjoy a chocolate milk every now and
again you do the mill like a gentleman
milk and you pour the chocolate and as
you're doing it you're stirring so you
can regulate the chocolate first is
stupid what do you how dark is that
gonna be do more and more people do that
Foley does the chocolate first I think
list and maybe Norman both did the
chocolate first people are writing in
that they're like if you put the milk in
first you're an idiot
which that's the way to do it milk first
I gotta be honest though I think I used
to do trouble at first every now and
again now I think about it because I
knew the level of how much it would give
me that's what everybody says yeah well
I syrup toast watch the syrup it was her
she chose a Hershey's guy gentleman for
one time my mom got stuck on the generic
America's choice from super fresh that
[ __ ] was that was like that would've
might as well been brown water dude that
[ __ ] did no work worse is [ __ ] legit
why are all your questions dairy based
so do you like turn your own butter okay
you cage free eggs what are you doing
the last kind of base that come one of
the common ones is you grew up in a
single house did you have a garage
fridge or like a basement for it like a
second fridge in the house so we did
right this is why I thought I was rich
when I was a kid but we had a meat guy
weed a guy who'd come to house corseting
karleusa yeah he had a meat guy and he
would give us a bunch of [ __ ] meat we
had it in his downstairs freezer that
also in the freezer you should know was
dead animals and my stepfather hunted
and above the freezer was guns that my
stepfather used to make he would take
the m1 garand which was the gun they
used in World War two he would get the
old pieces and he'd refurbish them and
then rebuild them and then
I don't know if that's legal I don't
know healthy futures you can sell guns
but he did it one time so sorry that
sorry to go he grabs me and I was like
seven or eight years old and uh he shows
me the gun stock and he goes you see
these see these crosses and I was like
yeah and he was like those are the
[ __ ] Nazis that were killed with this
thing or some [ __ ] and I was like all
right I'm gonna make some chocolate milk
I'll see you later go back and watch
Smurfs real quick he I see all the guns
he goes all of these guns killed Nazis
what have you done and I was like I
don't know man and I go judge woody when
all and it all goes down he he owes I go
what are all the guns for and he looks
at me and he goes for when it all goes
down I was seven or eight and he goes I
go hey George when it all goes down do I
get a gun and he goes no what you can
hold your [ __ ] and cry for your mommy
that is what he told me at seven or
eight years old and I was like I don't
have a [ __ ] dude I still don't be honest
[Laughter]
we need holy [ __ ] Greg stone this is
unreal um I got one one more food
question for you you have a choice
between these two items what do you go
with sponge cake or pound cake man this
is a hard one cuz I don't know I just
got into these things as an adult for
the apocalypse
hey don't touch that don't touch the
devil's food cake that's what allows for
the apocalypse mind and grenades in
there funny you should say that George's
main love was the chocolate Entenmann's
donut yellow inside
nothing is better than that I just
walked by that at the Acme Oh [ __ ]
end cab the case of them right back to
childhood they were made for stepdads
those things that's that's the [ __ ]
Stephie stepdads get those for [ __ ]
Christmas those things yeah there's a
large black rich chocolate frosted
doughnuts that's what they're called
nothing rich about that there's only
poor people in those things so you dunk
those in milk ice cold milk and it
hardens up the chocolate yeah only time
milk was allowed at the table no we
would have those Georgia you can dunk
that if you was black coffee at the
Stonehouse 1985 first Christmas my
stepfather is we meet my stepfather for
Christmas he bought us a gift he bought
me he bought me Gobots which was a
knockoff transformice very very happy
about them I open it I go to hug him he
puts his hand on my head and when men
don't hug and that is how I met my
stepfather Jesus who was he the [ __ ]
Marlboro Man what the [ __ ] a spitting
image sergeant slaughter the old
wrestler he looks exactly like that man
that's also a GI Joe character yes one
of my favorites I love this boy more
than I love him
would ya that's great I would love to
see the scene of George going out in the
80s a couple days before Christmas
trying to buy Gobots I'm looking for
something called a GoBot star this is a
Pep Boys you don't have him I got this
kid at home it sponge cake I like a
sponge cake
sorry shake now it's okay have you ever
been to a petting zoo Greg stone if I
heard me what petting zoo Oh recently
actually I went sausage my parents moved
up to they moved to Pennsylvania and now
they have like they have like this place
it's like the tiger King [ __ ] you know
it's like Billy's Billy's Bear house you
know pet some goats and those are fun
like I love that we're area they live in
the Poconos they live in a place called
the hideout
which is they've just moved up there
like a few years ago nice alone noses
clean living
I think the bushes house up that way
yeah the place my parents live in the
hideout which my mom was not this
Italian but the place is called the
hideout because it used to be where old
mobsters from Jersey would go to live to
hide out from from you know when it
would that he would come around the
corner you know what's funny is the the
Irishman really shined a lot of light on
that that there was a lot of like even
like scranton/wilkes-barre pitched in
the Poconos yeah there was a lot of [ __ ]
in New York and Jersey mob and Philly
mob that Lake was in that big circle
because you know out there and who was
looking yeah yeah yeah there was also a
lot of money because there's a lot of
vacation and resorts and [ __ ] out there
was like the Catskills guy so it was
like the place to get away to so there
was like money flow and then you know
the trucking the unions all that kind of
[ __ ]
also Foley just so you know doesn't get
doesn't that matter what you say to me
every time I see you ago hey I'm the
only Irish kid working at sea stealing
things and that's when I met the world
that's when I met Greg stone that's how
we did it back in the day me and stone
he was a good kid from Bloomfield slip
me a c-note Foley go steal that air
conditioner bring around back just a
Carl Lewis coming by that's the only
person you're the only person who ever
said it right that is exactly how you
say you [ __ ] Italian [ __ ] you know you
are you're [ __ ] on the run from
somebody you BG [ __ ] no he just doesn't
have a real identity he's just always
been doing characters and in the 90s he
just hit on Goodfellas and [ __ ] stuck
with that he's not read because he's
been acting about who he is [ __ ]
everybody and unfortunately I'm the only
person that sees the real him and it
ain't that's too funny are you from
Jersey no no okay Philly garbage
throwing through baby okay I'm sorry
have you ever doll this is a Part A and
A Part B so
answer a and then I'll then I'll fire B
have you ever ordered Domino's 5-5-5
deal so I don't want to see I'm playing
for a hundred percent garbage all the
way through I also have the 777 deal
which they came out a little later who I
am and what I am did that's in dominoes
in my house we had once a year because
it was an it was inappropriate mm-hmm
I'm Italian house we ordered from
amici's okay amici's pizza was the it
doesn't matter they could have charges a
hundred hours my house was not letting
Domino's through the [ __ ] door okay
we had that we had the real we had to
have the real [ __ ] Jersey which a lot of
people don't know northern Jersey has
some of the best pizza in the world it's
just it's that because New Yorkers they
live there and they [ __ ] move to
Jersey anyway New York gets a little bit
of cash and then tries you know goes out
to Long Island or you know so we have
great pizza
amici sounds pretty [ __ ] good I'll
tell you that oh geez man they were good
I got one here have you ever gone on
vacation to Florida done occasion we did
Disney World once and we never went on
vacation I went on vacation twice
because my north and friends parents
felt so bad for me that they took me on
vacation with them with friends like 50
bucks to two weeks in a row bo with the
[ __ ] Cartwright's down the street
yeah they're sleeping in a room with
some aunt that's also on the vacation
with the family too I had that man I had
to sleep next to some guys aunt brutal
what was the full she felt a full
question was have you ever gone on
vacation to Florida when you didn't go
to one of the shore points or Universal
or Disney anywhere else in Florida
you're [ __ ] garbage if you went if
you're going to like the middle of the
country or something my mom is
originally from Florida
like [ __ ] barefoot but they have
someone who busts they were like classic
redneck Florida people one of our uncles
or something had a had a billion dollars
because they own land that Disney bought
so
that they bought like all this land from
them and they were like to just [ __ ]
people who ate snakes with no sneakers
who then became me because Disney needed
their house but I did technically go on
a vacation I'm aligned to Destin Florida
because my granddad moved there and I
got to go down [ __ ] it's all right
sir William Dafoe lives I don't know why
anyone in your family ever owned the
minivan known as the Ford Aerostar they
all smelled like eggs and sulfur I
always had a red interior - red leather
interior way I got to look up to make
sure I had the arrow star but I'm pretty
sure my brother had it was like this it
was like the spaceship look at minivan
it was the first like like sports
edition oh my god I didn't have an arrow
star but my cross the street neighbor
did it we used to call it the chocolate
bus just wat'ry can dude named Emile who
would just play nothing but
Fat Joe every time we got in the car so
we would drive to the chocolate bus
which was a narrow star listening a fat
joke that's clean living right there
is there a drawer in your house now yes
a okay is there a drawing your house
right now that has like packets of
ketchup soy sauce plastic forks etc etc
things like that well you aren't tipping
on right now is such a contention in my
marriage this is because my wife is a
classy good human being with a good
heart and she married a son of a [ __ ]
from New Jersey we have that we have the
drunk Georgie gets mad at me for my junk
drawer oh yes
screws from who the [ __ ] knows what an
old battery a couple of wires some plugs
that don't work anymore to electronics
knows who the [ __ ] about what happened
to them
three poker chips just this is the
miscellaneous tool of the drunk drawer
the top half of a transformer growing up
we had multiple junk drawers they just
like campus bill it over into other
drawers yeah go to the kids house where
the dad had like his [ __ ] together and
there was no junk drawer but the dad had
like a perfect toolbox and like the
garage was all done nice then I go to my
[ __ ] house my dad did junk [ __ ] got
drill bits flashlight that doesn't work
yeah [ __ ] Zippo from Vietnam those
were big in the junk drawer ooh damn I
went over your house and you had your
extension cords we're hanging up in your
garage do we can't be friends
I bought a coat hanger that hangs on the
door four coats and I hang different
wires on them you are because you works
a little New York I do that at home as
well New York's a little different
because of the space for sure yeah look
you got a garage and you're so organized
that you're [ __ ] you're wrapping up
your extension cords like you're in your
own [ __ ] rat you know what I mean
that's - I see in the classic what like
in the clean way that's good yeah in the
shitty way that is I'm too stupid to put
them in a box so I hang them because
[ __ ] it not you got a mom coat hangers
that's [ __ ] what about this real
quick do you remember this got the both
II actually do you remember this is how
the kid being down there in Jersey Oh
getting through the road here's a little
Def Leppard to get you through the day
you guys ever remembered a time when you
were with your parents and they had to
ask somebody for a jump
the car wouldn't start and my mom's the
truck it pulls out these [ __ ] these
jumper cables there's no a jumper cables
and some guy was getting it was car next
was like hey you gotta jump where's this
going you've made a couple of wrong
turns if you gotta get jumped at like
the [ __ ] shop right super parking lot
dude my my I live in this weird crazy we
have like the suspicion that my mom was
a gambling problem because she was like
the head of an ER but we lived a block
at a Newark never had any money never
had anything so like every night my mom
would always have like not a nice car
but a car that worked um and one time my
sister needed money for she [ __ ] up
somehow and she needed money for college
or something I don't know what the [ __ ]
it was and my mom goes all right hang on
leaves comes back 4:00 in the morning
hands my sister $3,000 and goes there
you go and so my mom was a card shark
she would just play five-card stud she
so she needed money that's looking
badass game a couple of guns pulls on
you playing five-card stud
drove to Atlantic City went all night in
some poker tournament or you know pie up
pie down her nose but came back with the
money ahead of my sister mrs. Logan now
now we're all like we never had money
because our mom had a gambling problem
I mean it's so clear it's gotta be we
don't really know for sure I hate to
shoot at my mom I love my mom
that's so funny it's questionable what
the fire the money was going where was
going and yeah it was very weird what's
that gonna doing get in the car jokes
nothing I just like to talk to them you
can't go to the feds with this kind of
stuff right Gemma take a man's life I
have no idea I don't know I just like
you send out your lighting these weird
your lighting these weird memories
that's that's kind of the thing that
everybody realizes is like holy [ __ ] I
haven't thought about that for so long
it's yeah people are really digging it
at school all right I got another one
while we're have you ever looked for car
parts in a junkyard car parts in a
junkyard
yeah like I'm gonna go get a headlight
you know my mom did that man she did it
a couple of weeks ago Aerostar back she
was drunk driving and hit out sideswiped
the [ __ ] mailbox my my next-door
neighbor were these three brothers named
Jose who is Jose Manny Jose and Oh
cielito there was a three brothers they
were all named Jose and they were they
build cars in their back yard and [ __ ]
and we jumped the brick wall to get into
some guys garage because they had like
where the car parts were to find like it
was like the back lights of a Honda
Civic or something we got some and then
we found there was [ __ ] dog hence
junkyard dogs [ __ ] start chasing us
we had the [ __ ] climb this thing and
jump back just a fun thing it was it was
the back lights for it was the front
lights for my most my car had a
Volkswagen Golf GL teal whose the same
color as this this shirt cuz I just
wanted one so bad I want one so bad I
didn't get the dollar it didn't matter
yeah I got hit in the front
I got hit and this is how they fixed it
I had no money to get this car fixed so
we jumped the thing to steal the lights
we stole the lights then to fix the
front end of the car my friend the man
he goes this is how we fix it we don't
need a guy tied a rope to the front of
my car to the frame tied the other end
of the rope to a tree and then slowly
reverse the car and it's straightened
out and right and then we literally fix
it ourselves put the lights in three or
four years later a similar situation I'm
like I don't how to do this I remember
so Manny did this I tie it to the front
tied to a tree hit reverse the whole
tree comes down on my [ __ ] oh my god
that's insane
looking back was again I was a little as
tree so it didn't do too much damage but
it [ __ ] it smash the windshield and
hooked it up to a rhododendron in
somebody's front yard yeah that's too
funny
I kept the plant though it's actually a
beautiful place Jesus Christ
alright I got I got two so shout out all
the listeners first of all rate review
subscribe all that kind of business if
you haven't already we appreciate it but
people are hitting us up with a lot of
[ __ ] questions on your life no no no
but I forgot to do the know as they're
emailing you so any use wait a while
what's going on in I don't know if we're
gonna be able to get to all of them not
definite whatever these are two from
Drew have you ever hung out at a grocery
store loading dock grocery store loading
dock now people my family did cuz they
worked there I didn't but I used to hang
out at the ER loading dock where the
patient's would come in as I worked in
in there trying to get bills it fell out
looking for berkos another one have you
ever been a competition what no sack
race like a [ __ ] gentleman I'll
[ __ ] put an egg on a spoon and run
back and forth or spin around a baseball
bat a greased watermelon at swim clubs
you know I forth whatever I used to go
to [ __ ] rich Pro Swim Club and we'd
[ __ ] grease up a watermelon once a
year and throw it into the deep end and
there would be like two teams like ten
and ten or twenty and twenty and you had
to try to get the grease it was all
covered in Vaseline you had to get it
off to the other side real garbage [ __ ]
and then everybody would each me
everybody would eat the watermelon you
don't eat the rind you know what I mean
you just eat the red liquid look at
everybody's hands dirty you ever play on
train tracks
Greg stone you ever play around the
train tracks
yeah well we didn't call them train
tracks in our town who is the tracks you
go to the tracks and the tracks
that's where bridge ride bikes cuz they
do have like trails and [ __ ] and we're
gonna have to jump over homeless
pedophile so we try to get you because
that's also you had two types of groups
hanging out two tracks
you had kids smoke cigarettes and
homeless pedophile so we're trying to
rape kids
look at the smoke cigarettes and if you
found the right rock you could find some
pornography but that's those were the
tracks by our house that was the fine
defined in porno mags in the woods man
that was like [ __ ] find an Eldorado
that was [ __ ] that was every kid's
dream you pulled over some piece of
plywood and there was a couple of
[ __ ] cherry magazines like wow dude
there was a there was a deli by my house
that I look I'll walk into the deli and
you'd see like the comic books would be
down here and the top shelf was a porno
mags and then above the porno mags was
this giant fan right - like you know air
out the building and I look I go fan
there's no fence right like it was just
you pull it up and pull it down so I
went back in the middle at night we
brought a little brick you know like a
little Meg cart you know egg carton you
know where those things called cuz I
crates cream milk crate right
no crates reached our hands into the
[ __ ] milk for dinner
we start hands into the fan and just
grabbed pornos and we had I was selling
pornos in high school because I was we
wouldn't talk to you I mean what the
[ __ ]
and then I started in college I started
producing it they had to do that when
the things had to cool down at Sears for
a little while when Chris was running
his mouth you ever the first one ever
stole was called Toshi con carne and it
advertised a thousand percent anal oh we
had a thousand presenting on this VHS it
was a VHS tape I remember that [ __ ] all
right yes have you ever gotten cable
from something known as a black box or a
hot box
oh yeah the black box man we just get
WrestleManias on the black box maybe my
body had the spice channel that was huge
as a kid
dude I one time jerking off to the
squigglies member was squiggly yes I was
jerking off to the squigglies and
it got clear for three minutes and I
realized I was just watching an
operation Dumbo drop I was master day to
an elephant's nose I think just the idea
of it like you would see those
squigglies were no joke man but like
you'd like caps like a little bit of
boob would shake and then slow and like
roll up the side of this and I tell you
wonder what it was your fantasy of like
what's go it was it was if the movie
would actually been clear you'd be like
goddess whatever not whatever but your
fantasy of it that's extreme though your
your imagination is way more enticing
than what it actually was a friend of
meal the kid outside my before his TV
for some reason was [ __ ] up and from
ADAC Playboy we coming out of a p.m. for
some reason he always got the first four
minutes of Playboy because it would go
from like the box which like a channel
called which like which like videos
music videos her stuff 8 o'clock the box
would be done and it would switch to
Playboy but for some reason he always
got the first four minutes of Playboy
for real like he got at the aim and so
he would VHS tape the first four minutes
every night so he had a in this VHS tape
of just the first four minutes of
Playboy and 90% of it was set up you
know and then coming Goods yeah yeah but
the idea that this days playboy was a
number yeah that's enough for me now
there it's [ __ ] genius what company
is this guy running now he's he a
senator a congress that's [ __ ] genius
we've no idea why his TV would just give
you it was just late it was the first
four minutes so the squigglies wouldn't
come in for like four minutes or
something I thought that was about it's
crazy crazy
Kippy yeah I got one or two more here um
that have you ever waited in line to
shop on Black Friday as a retail
employee uh there isn't a sale you could
give me that will die will degrade
myself to doing that
yes I'm like I don't give a look I get
it you want to go [ __ ] get your sale
you know you want to shop your kids
I'll pay I don't give a [ __ ] I'll pay
the money or I won't have the [ __ ]
thing I am NOT I I worked on the other
end of that you ever do that [ __ ]
I would pay an additional 20% to not
[ __ ] to not do that you know what I
mean it'd be like I'll pay I'll pay more
than full price if you just bring it to
my house yeah yeah we used to like going
shopping on the day after Thanksgiving
on Black Friday but for some reason it
wasn't like that we would just the whole
family like the extended family the
cousins would go to the King of Prussia
Mall at like you know 11 and like 11
o'clock we go we hit the food court it
was like a fun day it wasn't less than
no way the first place the Folies line
was the [ __ ] food court yeah little
walk and roll in this little guys
they're under Orange Julius that's what
I'm talking yeah dude where are you are
you my cousin's from King of Prussia
they they used to do a pizza place
called Spinelli's over there somewhere
you know Spinelli's yeah I don't think
I've ever eaten there but I know what
you're talking about I'm like maybe 15
minutes north of King of Prussia alright
yeah just on the other side in
Norristown Buxton County is that right
is that a thing I live in Bucks County
families from yeah yeah yep I dated a
girl from Manayunk once and she showed
me brunch brunch is a very mania and
kind of thing it's all like it's all
like rich college kids that say we're
like yeah they get a job in finance and
then moved to tomainia George wasn't a
big brunch guy growing up you didn't do
a nice little cantaloupe with that with
a nice frittata
yeah maybe a mimosa or something for
breakfast me at London broil
Salsbury steak for breakfast set of
unsalted potatoes I just got one last
question I hunted percent might be the
most garbage that we've had on the show
and I say that I'd say that I say that
with love of course I don't I mean this
is I mean I don't know I don't know who
else illicit illegal activities - Shady
I'm so proud of myself
I think Donnelly Donnelly was pretty
trashy as well but it was pretty trashy
yeah his dad like his dad was like a
bodyguard or a bouncer at a McDonald's
or something
I don't think usually realized that the
piece of [ __ ] that I I think people look
at me usually they go oh there's just
like a fun white guy from white town USA
it's like oh it was a real people off
you throw people off with the comic
books and the action figures and all
that kind of doing that now because I
didn't do it when I was a kid you know
I'm just getting to be the child I want
to either be a man when I was 12 so now
if I let me do all the toys now yeah for
sure I ain't elements because you stone
you're very nice and personable and hey
you walk in hi to everybody you're like
very nice you're a great guy you're a
great guy and I think it takes that a
lot like you learned that from being
like oh I was a piece of [ __ ] before and
I've seen I have associated with known
criminals and like all this stuff's is
like you live i I think you know you're
that when you live it when you have it
trash your up ring and you live more of
a life by the time you're 20 then a lot
of people so it's like you realize
you're you're like older and wiser and
you know you're like I don't need to do
all this I'm just polite to everybody
these [ __ ] chumps anyway yeah this is
so much fun you guys great my final
question for you Greg stone is have you
or any member of your family ever owned
a timeshare
because George sounds like a timeshare
guy so it's hard to say because we so we
technically didn't but we didn't have to
because our neighbors did and they had
some kind of deal where he'd be like
I'll fix your car you let us use a
timeshare and a member going to the
Poconos timeshare in the Poconos which
why I mean yeah best way to spend thirty
five bucks a year why would do that I
never said that out loud we had a they
do those timeshare in the Poconos and it
was like a shittier house than the one
we lived in and then yeah going to a
worse place but yeah that's the closest
I had with the timeshare Oh Greg stone
you are absolute garbage and I love you
buddy is there anything you want the
other gangs out there to know like could
I tell them at my podcast is that dude
if you enjoyed me check out my podcast
the rad dude cast and also every Friday
night I do Friday night Greg that's my
late night show it's live on YouTube and
you can also just watch the old ones on
YouTube well my name's uh Greg F Stone
and all that [ __ ] anyway you I don't
even care about that you guys are
wonderful human beings thank you so I
know I demanded to be on this but it
just looked like so much fun and you
guys are so much fun and I missed you
both thank you so much [ __ ] awesome
thank you so much
guys first of all thank you for all the
support as we've gotten this thing off
the ground I know a lot of tews gays are
tuning in because they gave us a shout
out on the pod so we appreciate it
but please make sure you rate review and
subscribe on iTunes Spotify stitcher
wherever you listen to pods and if you
watch pods we're on YouTube make sure
you subscribe and you comment we mix it
up in the comments all that fun stuff
and i'm at kevin ryan comedy on all
social media very nice at h folio on ice
on twitter and foley grams on instagram
just to reiterate what Kevin said guys
thank you so much for appreciate all the
love all the support love going back and
forth of everybody on social media
please continue to support the podcast
tell a friend spread the word Greg stone
the king of garbage right
now buddy you're [ __ ] number one it's
great we're gonna happen to have [ __ ]
like what I don't know who we're gonna
have that long we have to get our Kelly
or some buddy thank you so much we
appreciate you coming man thanks man
appreciate it